der fünfte lotion muss ich echt sagen
ist für mich wirklich die aller coolste
guten das video kommt am abend ja guten
abend meine lieben freunde und herzlich
willkommen zu einem video über die
schied durch jungen libere optische über
optische täuschungen in minecraft
zusammengebaut haben einen mann
ich hör auf mit diesem print rohkakao
das ist doch ich fakten da herzlich
willkommen zu einem video über optische
täuschungen was ich beim mister creative
iv ich meine so hieß es auch sonst ganz
coole videos auf dem kanal auf jeden
fall mal vorbeigucken hab ich euch auf
die die beschreibung vorliegt er hat
davon ein video hochgeladen er hat das
ganze hier nicht gebaut sondern das
wurde gebaut von big blue ray das heißt
world of illusion da findet ihr auch den
forum artikel mikrofone beschreibung und
zwar sind dort fünf welten die ihr euch
runterladen könnt ich habe eine 500
gleich dass er zeigen in einem kurzen
video werde ich ganz cool findet und er
hat dann einfach so wählten gebaut wo
optische illusionen stadt finde ich habe
schon zwei dreimal in minecraft facts
folgen gezeigt und auch schon mal eine
runde halten zieht darüber gesprochen
über optische illusion das ist
eigentlich ganz geil ist und wollte euch
das ganze dauert minecraft zeigen weil
das ganze in minecraft auch funktioniert
zumindest wenn zugebaut wird wie es hier
gebaut wird und ich hab das halt bei
mister creative iv gesehen und ich bin
jetzt einfach sagen ich wollte ich das
auch mal zeigen und nicht etwa die erste
sache ist diese unendliche treppe und
zwar sehen wir hier schon immer mein
sport halt immer auf zum goldenen blog
unternehmen steht dieses schild ränder
distance auf far the illusion blabla wie
man das einstellen soll
und man sollte sich halt schon so
relativ genau hier hinstellen und ihr
seht schon da vorne
okay wenn ich jetzt halt nicht weil
jetzt schon sehen wie das ganze
funktioniert aber so seht ihr schon wenn
man sich das so anguckt okay da geht es
runter da geht's runter da geht's runter
und da geht's runter dann ist man auf
einmal wieder hier drauf was eigentlich
nicht sein kann das ist das aus aus aus
aus aus aus dem film inception was einer
meiner lieblingsfilme ist ist das extrem
cool auf dargestellt wo auch eine treppe
weiter runter geht
und so denkt man wenn man immer weiter
runter geht wie soll man dann wieder
weiter oben sache ankommen allerdings
wenn ich mal so hoch fliege seht ihr
schon kannte wurde gebaut
also wenn ich von oben cook ist das echt
so zack zack zack und zack das heißt ihr
wisst auch schon wenn ich von hier wenn
jeder gold blog wäre wird das ganze auch
nicht funktionieren so sieht das ganze
unten aus als sie sich schon das geht so
runter das geht runter das geht runter
also letztendlich wenn ich hier bin bin
ich auch nicht wieder hier sondern ich
bin selbstverständlich dann weiter unten
weil ich ja quasi die treppe runter gehe
aber wenn ich mich mal hier auf den gold
blog drauf stelle oder irgendwo hier
sind die umgebung gehe sehe schon hier
schaut mal wenn ich dann natürlich nicht
aber so sieht das aus wirklich als wenn
ich immer sonne dritte weiter
runtergehen würde und ich würden immer
quasi auf der gleichen höhe bleiben
jetzigen also immer wieder oben ankommen
das optische täuschung mal sony kommt
optische täuschung nummer zwei wir
befinden uns jetzt hier bei der zweiten
optischen täuschung und zwar seht ihr
schon das ist so ein ganz normaler
würfel mit gelben kugel allerdings
bildet der kugel auf werde die die kugel
nicht der kugel die kugel auf die wir
hier drauf gucken ihr seht schon wieder
natürlich ist es eine optische täuschung
deswegen aber mit summen kann man es
einfach am besten zeigen ihr seht die
kugel in der mitte hier bildet
einerseits die kugel die von dem blog da
unten so klar wie hoch geschoben wird
aber andererseits auch die kugel die da
hinten um die ecke rum ist und mit allen
google verbundes was also quasi
eigentlich überhaupt nicht möglich wäre
ohne dass irgendein roter stark verbogen
werden wie halo fans kein okay die
bürger wieder müssen uns auf das ganze
besteht einfach aus zwei komische gleich
teiligen sachen und es sieht von hinter
einfach aus diesen fünf damit quasi hier
einfach wasser vorne gestellt ist wegen
sie die kugeln hier vorne auch
dementsprechend kleiner als die kugel
nach hinten dass er einfach wenn ihr
euch jemals den durchmesser anschaut und
hier beispielsweise durchmesser anschaut
oder da hinten die bands ganz gut von
den roten stehen wieder reingehen weil
ganz einfach die sachen die nähe am
betrachter sind dürfen kleiner sein weil
die dementsprechend größer wirken und
die sagten die weiter weg sind müssen
dementsprechend grösser sein damit die
gleiche größe ist man denkt dass es ein
würfel ist deswegen sieht das ganze land
von hier hinten in etwa metal müsse ich
sogar noch ein bisschen höher stehen
denke ich also ich müsste mich in etwa
so hier hinstellen die schon dass ich da
hinten so aus als wenn das ganze okay
die position ist nicht so perfekt
gewählt
ich gehe noch ein bisschen hier so sieht
es ganz gut aus so spitze spielt die
modifizierte meine süße denkst das ist
ein würfel aber eigentlich sind diese
ganzen sachen hier nicht mit den kugeln
verbunden sondern auch hier weiter
vorher das sieht man schon wenn man nur
ein mitarbeiter vor fliegt sieht man das
schon
also das ist auch extrem cool das hier
ist optische illusion
mai und zwar schon das sind alles ganz
normal
gerade blöcke denkt man zumindest wenn
man aber so an zoomen denkt man es okay
das sind alles so hier solche irgendwie
und textmarker oder sie übrigens danke
für stabile dankern stabilo für den
textmarker ich bekommen dafür dass die
reds hier zeigen und zufällig als
beispiel benutzt bekomme ich eher von
stabilo zehn millionen euro dafür ich
esse ich nicht aus meiner nase los ist
die juckt wie was behindertes alter ich
weiß ich bin ich ging ebenfalls
allergisch gegen textmarker oder so mal
durch das nase jucken liegt auch noch
meinen augen sondern bisschen irgendwie
ich glaube ich einfach wieder krank
nicht zufällig aus ich muss einfach
immer noch vor produzieren weil ich in
frankfurt bin weniger hat das video seht
und das ist halt einfach gerade zwei 34
und ich muss in viereinhalb stunden
aufstehen anna jakobs optischen
täuschung zurück und zwar ist das so wie
mit so viel leider sagt mal die habe ich
hier auch übrigens auch von stabilo auch
bekomme ich fünf millionen euro für das
ist ein spaß jedenfalls ihr da schon
wenn die immer so sind die können nicht
nur gerade sein die müssen verboten sein
weil da halt diese anderen stifter wenn
ihr das mal hier seht diese teile müssen
da halt irgendwie so noch drunter her
und alles möglich und die gehen ja hier
darunter her und dann geht das hier so
erst darüber und wieder darunter die
wieder darüber und darunter dann muss
das eigentlich verboten sein
allerdings ist das eine optische
täuschung und zwar wenn wir mal hierhin
fliegen und schauen ihr seht schon wenn
ich noch ein paar gewinnt zwar auf einer
höhe gebaut aber
da sind so stufen treppen ähnliche
sachen gebaut und sogar ganz viel liebe
zum detail
die haben hier sogar extra teil weil
sich hier noch einen bock hingestellt
weil das man hier dann so aussieht wenn
man zu oben drauf guckt dass da noch
sein blogs und das so runtergeht und
damit den block dann so verbunden ist
also das haben die ihnen natürlich immer
verbunden damit dass hier ganz gut
aussieht aber hier haben die halt immer
diese stufen ähnlichen sache macht eben
damit es so wirkt als wenn das ganze
halt verbunden ist und bzw
da drunter her geht ihr denkt ihr seht
schon okay das geht hier lang das geht
dann so darunter her
wenn ich an summe jetzt natürlich nicht
aber wenn ich mich einfach mal da oben
jetzt drauf stelle seht ihr schon das
wird immer mehr zu
jetzt ist die optische täuschung auf
jeden fall mehr als nur perfekte
illusion nummer vier wird präsentiert
von wetten dass immer wieder leute ernst
herrmann
naja egal ob in falludscha ich will dich
pops und schlafmangel 04 ist es quasi
genau das gleiche wie nummer 30 mit zum
würfel dinge macht das jetzt nichts
großartig anderes aber ihr seht schon
wenn ich mal von hier gucke denkt man
okay das geht drunter her und es geht
drunter her aber wenn man sie schon okay
das gut mit sondern mit zum stufen
ähnlichen treppen dingen wieder gemacht
einfach dass wenn man von von hier vorne
wieder guckt dass es so aussieht als
wird das ding runter hergehen wenn ich
allerdings mal von einer anderen seite
seht ihr schon das verbot und gucke ich
quasi direkt auf dieser stufe drauf das
wirkt er natürlich auf gar keinen fall
wie irgend eine optische illusion oder
so man muss es nämlich immer wieder von
wirklich diesem punkt da betrachten den
ich da schon an fokussiere von diesem
steinblock hier zum beispiel damit das
ganze wirklich eine optische täuschung
noch bewahrheiten kann und das ist
sachen mache ich weiß noch nicht was
dazu sagen soll
aber euch einfach so ein link zu
schicken dazu helfen euch ganz doof
deswegen wieder erreicht weil immer die
meisten leute geht auf jeden fall mal
ins forum und ich komme übrigens erst
mal 240 euro 5 bevor ich die angaben
machen
der fünfte lotion muss sich echt sagen
ist für mich wirklich die aller coolste
und zwar diese sache mit diesem würfel
ich denke das sieht man schon auf den
ersten blick wenn ich jetzt natürlich
nicht ran somit ist natürlich ihr wisst
dass bäume wieder das prinzip man denkt
das ist davor und dahinter das heißt man
muss da etwas mit wieder mit diesen
treppen arbeiten aber ich muss echt
sagen ich finde es ist mit die coolste
illusion weil sondern würfel dieser eine
ecke ganz hinten ist natürlich der ecke
ganz hinten aber die muss trotzdem
irgendwie weiter vorne sein weil sie vor
diesen diesem ding hier ist aber sie ist
eigentlich weiterhin und alles mögliche
und es ist quasi unmöglich deswegen ist
eine optische täuschung ist eigentlich
unmögliches war zu errichten aber also
ohne jetzt irgendwelche sachen dazu
verbiegen oder irgendwelche anderen
materialien zu nutzen echten leben aber
es ist halt echt hier wieder so mit
diesem mit diesem stufen prinzip
gearbeitet worden also auch eine extrem
coole sache und ich muss wirklich sagen
freunde ich bin extrem proud of die
minecraft community that we can reach
dass wir nicht nur diese höhe erreichen
können sondern die höhe mit den maps die
hochgeladen werden da muss ich sagen da
bin ich einfach nur gut drauf was ich
bin müde fristet letzte video weiß ich
wo produzieren
ich glaube da kommt am montag noch
nummer ich habe mir extra ablaufplan
gemacht ich zeig euch immer nur von der
rückseite wäre hier seht ihr schon die
zahlen und so wegen urlaub wegfahren und
oder arbeite das youtube damit
entwickelt sich wirklich zu arbeiten
wenn man viel viel zeit darin investiert
muss ich dann diesen ganzen ablaufplan
was sich hochladen und so saß ich
einfach zwei stunden bieten etwa daran
dass ich nicht so einer bin einfach ein
projekt hat was durchläuft sowie andere
kanäle sondern weil ich einfach immer so
bei mir ist jeden tag auf andere sind
deshalb box wünscht der kann natürlich
ein bisschen aufregend aber andererseits
finde ich dass ein ganz klein bisschen
abwechslung und so und ja ich würde auf
jeden fall sagen
wenn es euch gefallen hat wirklich eine
bewertung lassen wenn ihr mehr solcher
lustigen coolen videos wo man was lernen
kann irgendwie okay was habt jetzt
gelernt eigentlich nicht trotzdem will
ich mich darüber sehr freuen und würde
ich mich noch mehr freuen würde wäre
einfach wenn ihm als micro umgeht und
dem typen sagt haye kommen ist egal
gemacht einfach ihr müsst ihr mann jakob
dabei als kalt macht sondern einfach nur
in den unterstützen weil ich finde sowas
muss gefördert werden
wenn man wirklich ab zeit ein investiert
ich meine der muss er von jeder position
aber gucken hier setzt jetzt noch ein
block hin oder nicht oder niest oder das
ist was ich meine